desde hace 10 años los autos eléctricos
son una parte importante de la vida de
richard ins cuando tuvo el primero la
compañía eléctrica la instaló de forma
gratuita un cargador rápido de baterías
desde entonces ha tenido varios
vehículos eléctricos renovando los
modelos a medida que avanza la
tecnología surgen después de 10 años de
hacer esto sabemos exactamente dónde
cargar cómo conducir para poder recorrer
la mayor cantidad de kilómetros así que
mi esposa y yo ya no nos preocupamos por
la autonomía del vehículo a pesar de que
unos problemas iniciales en los autos
eléctricos se han resuelto sólo
representan el 10 por ciento de las
ventas de vehículos en california el
objetivo el 100 por ciento para 2035
creo que será muy difícil o al menos
extremadamente costoso alcanzar ese
objetivo porque todavía necesitamos
miles de dólares en subvenciones para
que los vehículos eléctricos tengan un
precio competitivo frente a los autos a
combustible
winter's tanto el gobierno federal como
el estado de california reembolsarán
hasta siete mil dólares por la compra de
un vehículo eléctrico
además del costo los vehículos
eléctricos tienen otros problemas
potenciales que podrían afectar a los
compradores como el número de estaciones
de recarga hoy en día 73 mil en
california que es más de lo que tiene
francia en todo el país pero los
funcionarios estiman que se necesitarán
un millón doscientos en california para
2030 otro inconveniente el tiempo que se
tarda en cargar la batería 30 minutos es
el mínimo y la media es de 3 a 4 horas
esto influye en fort awards para
combatir estos problemas
california confía en pequeñas empresas
emergentes como esta al sur de los
ángeles que dice haber encontrado una
solución con un nuevo tipo de batería
verdad nadie
tenemos nuestra tecnología con ánodos de
silicona y tecnología de celdas es lo
que llamamos la carga extremadamente
rápida ahora se puede viajar y tener una
capacidad de carga rápida similar a un
coche con un motor de gasolina tiene más
vez
carstens esta nueva tecnología de
baterías podría incorporarse el próximo
año a los vehículos eléctricos ayudando
a california a seguir siendo el líder en
electromovilidad